[Music]  the chat was so [ __ ] mad dude justin  bieber you [ __ ] up the live stream it  was new year's eve and uh this is like  two years ago now 2020. justin bieber  did a like a live stream in during  covid's you can't have like concerts so  he did a live stream yeah we we found  someone that was restreaming it on  twitch  but they had their own like emotes like  sound effects when you bought when you  donated at every single crescendo of  justin bieber's most popular hits we  would donate like the biggest one and it  would play turned down for what  so if you're like is it too late now to  turn down for once  you're trying to try to make the noise  i'm trying to nail the tone  [Music]  stop playing turn down for what guys  stop